رائع
هذا ما تبدو عليه الإجازة
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
إنها ليلة الاثنين
والجادة مزدحمة للغاية ،
هذه ليست دبي أو الدوحة ،
إنها الرياض
وليس ما كنت أتوقعه على الإطلاق.
إلى السعودية عدة مرات للعمل
هذه المرة يبدو الأمر
مختلفًا.
هذا رائع. أحب هذه الأغنية
[موسيقى] ،
لا يمكنك
إعادة الجني إلى هذه الزجاجة ، هل
يمكنني أن لا أرى حدوثها
لبضع سنوات قصيرة  منذ عقود ولعقود من الزمان ، كانت
مشاهد مثل هذه من المحرمات
على الموسيقى
للرجال والنساء الذين يتواصلون مع الناس في الأماكن العامة ،
هذا هو الشارع وهو
حي ترفيهي جديد تم تشييده لهذا
الغرض بالذات ،
هذه لوحة جدارية جميلة من قبل
فنانة سعودية رفيقتي في المساء
روجر السنا امرأة أبناء.  راجا كاهنة الشعر
المتدفقة الخالية من الشعر
تعرف الأيام القديمة عندما
استاءت من
الازدراء بسبب فتياتها الروائيات في
الرياض ، وهي قصة خيالية لأربع
نساء سعوديات وحبهن غير المشروع ،
راجا يربح عندما أصفه بأنه
جنس سعودي في المدينة ولكن  لأكون صادقًا ، هذا
ما يصور
[الموسيقى
] الشارع يذهب بعيدًا ولكن لا
تنخدع بالتقاليد ولا يزال الدين في
المقدمة والوسط.
الموسيقى
] يمكن رؤية التجاور هنا في
قلعة المصمك الهائلة حيث
بدأت عائلة آل سعود حكمها للمملكة
العربية السعودية في عام 1932.
هذا موقع
عادي في أي وجهة عالمية أخرى
ولكن هنا شيء رائع
للسياح الممالك فتحته للتو و
دفع لتحرير اقتصادها
لفطمها عن أموال النفط
، الرجل الذي يقف وراء التحول في الحياة السعودية
هو ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان محمد بن سلمان
، الذي تعرض لانتقادات شديدة بسبب
سجل حقوق الإنسان في البلاد
، ويقول الكثيرون إنه كان انتقائيًا في إصلاحاته
على سبيل المثال أثناء السماح  سيدات
لقيادة السيارة
، لا يزال هناك مساحة صغيرة جدًا
لروجر من أصل عام معي
هذه المرة خلف عجلة القيادة ،
يا سائقة ، انظر إلى
جامعة الملك السعودية ، هذا هو
المكان الذي نحن فيه  في مدرسة طب الأسنان
، تعد الحريات اليوم
تذكيرًا بالقيود التي كانت سائدة في العام الماضي ،
فهي مهمة لأنه مع هذه الحريات الجديدة ،
يكون الشباب والموهوبون
مستعدين للبقاء في المملكة العربية السعودية ، هذا
موقع تراثي
لليونسكو ، لقد دفعتني راجا إلى خارج الرياض
للتعرفة في أدريا.  هذا مثير ،
أشعر وكأنني متاهة
كريستالية لطفل ،
أتذكر أن
هذه المتاهة داخل عاصمة
الدولة السعودية الأولى ، لذا فهذه هي
مسقط رأسها ، هذا هو هذا
إذا كنت ترغب في ذلك ، فهذه هي بداية
السلالة السعودية التي
أجدها  من المثير للاهتمام حقًا
أنك بقيت هنا ، وكان
الخيار السهل هو الذهاب إلى لندن باريس أو
نيويورك لأنك كتبت الكتاب لأنك قرأت
لماذا كانت هذه ثورة
تكتب عن قضايا المرأة
والحب
والحياة الاجتماعية كل يوم و  نضالات
العمل ، الكفاح من أجل
معالجة هذه الحياة التي
تحافظ على التراث ، مع اقترابنا من
القرن الحادي والعشرين ،
نحن نعيد تعلم تاريخنا بصراحة ،
نحن مندهشون للغاية ، ونحن حريصون جدًا على ذلك.  ger to know نحن
حريصون جدًا على امتلاك هذه الثقافة ، فإن
زيارتي إلى المملكة العربية السعودية ستكون صعبة
ومبهجة
لك